Hello students,
welcome to the drugs
used in coagulation
disorders, part two.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
This video will describe
the pharmacology of the
fibrinolytics, sometimes
called thrombolytics,
antiplatelet agents, and
antidotes for the
anticoagulants.
Learning objectives
are the same, really,
because this is, even
though it's in two videos,
it's really one lecture
preparation and links
and here are the key
concepts for fibrinolytics
antiplatelet agents
and reversal agents the
fibrinolytic agents are
alteplase tenecteplase and
retiplase I put a star only
on alteplase it was the
first one it is actually
TPA and streptokinase is a
natural product it's not
available in the US so why am
I including it in this video
you don't have to memorize
it I didn't put a star
on it but you do need to
be familiar with its mechanism
it's slightly different
than the others it was the
first fibrinolytic agent
available and it can still
appear on a board exam.
Fibrinolysis or fibrinolysis
is the process of
fibrin digestion by fibrin
specific protease plasmid.
And we see this figure
again here. Here is TPA.
That's what I want to point
out this time oops sorry
and this is the point
at which our drugs are
working tissue plasminogen
activator including our
alteplase will allow
conversion of plasminogen to
plasmin and then plasmin
will cleave those fibrin
molecules and release
the fibrin mesh.
Structure activity
relationship. You do not need
to recreate this structure.
This is TPA here at
the top. This is the natural
structure of our TPA.
These, I'm having lots of
trouble here with my power.
These structures here, these
kind of round structures
it's really just the way the
protein is folded are called
kringle domains and they
got the name from kringle
cookies which are Scandinavian
cookies and I have a
picture of it here and you
can see it says kringle on it
so that's why they're called
the kringle domain and
that's the responsible for
the activity of the drug so
alteplase the same as
the original same as the
endogenous tpa then there are
some structural changes to
in this case increase the
half-life this is a much
smaller version got a longer
half-life than alteplase 2
um alteplase and tenecteplase
to my understanding
are in common use reteplase
less so but you may
see it IV rapid hepatic
clearance alteplase has
a half-life of less than
five minutes so how do
you think it's administered
by continuous infusion
tenecteplase has a half
-life of about 20 minutes
but a terminal half-life
of more like two hours.
And retiplase has a
half-life of about 15
minutes. So these
drugs have this longer
half-life, and so
they can be given by a
bolus dose, or possibly
two bolus doses.
A fibrinolytic is not
intended as a routine
drug. It's just for that
emergent situation of
trying to get reperfusion
of a thrombotic vessel,
of a vessel that's
obstructed with a thrombus.
Fibrinolytic agents catalyze
the formation of plasmid
from its precursor plasminogen.
Very simple concept.
They induce rapid
dissolution of the thrombi.
That's what TPA does.
Both protective hemostatic
thrombi and the target
thrombi, such as
the thrombus in the
ischemic ******, the vessel
causing the ischemia
in the coronary vessel,
these are the target
thromboemboli.
But hemostatic, our natural
ones that we want, are
also broken down.
fibrinolytic is being put into
a vein after all as a
result a generalized lytic
stage can occur and
generalized we have to think
about hemorrhage so
fibrinolytics are used for acute
ischemic ****** to
decrease neuronal death or
infarction, it needs to
be administered within 4
.5, four and a half hours
of the onset of symptoms.
The ST elevation myocardial
infarction, if the patient
can't be gotten to the
cath lab for a balloon
angioplasty a percutaneous
coronary intervention within
120 minutes two hours in this
case it's best to administer
the drug within 30 minutes
of the first medical
contact if the patient has
continuing ischemia and
can't get to the cath lab
then it can be administered
later it's all it's administered
with an antiplatelet
and an anticoagulant at
the same time so you can
imagine there's quite a big
risk for bleeding in this
case but all of those drugs
are needed to stop they
to cut to open the vessel
it's also used for pulmonary
embolism and active the
alteplase can be used just
to open up catheters central
venous catheter or dialysis
catheter adverse effects
hemorrhage hemorrhage
hemorrhagic ****** and this
results from the lysis of
the hemostatic plugs just
in the general circulation
streptokinase now this
actually comes from beta
hemolytic streptococci so
streptokinase forms a complex
now with plasminogen so we
see that in this picture
complex induces the
conformational change in the
plasminogen exposing the active
site. And then the complex
cleaves plasminogen into
plasmin. That's basically it.
Now, some patients may have
antibodies against beta
-hemolytic streptococcus.
And as a result, there
can be a hypersensitivity
reaction to the streptokinase
because of that there are a
bunch of contraindications
with the use of a
fibrinolytic there are
some absolute contraindications
mean don't use it
prior intracranial hemorrhage
known structural cerebral
vascular lesion you can
just imagine the hemorrhage
that can occur malignant
intracranial neoplasm
ischemic ****** within three
months, suspected
aortic dissection,
active bleeding or
bleeding diastasis,
that doesn't include
a menstrual period,
significant closed
head trauma or
facial trauma
within three months.
Relative contraindications
means don't use it unless
you're saving the life. So
uncontrolled hypertension,
traumatic or prolonged CPR or
major surgery
within three weeks,
recent internal bleeding,
non-compressible
vascular punctures.
We have the streptokinase
here, prior exposure more
than five days ago because
there might be antibodies
against it which could
cause an allergic reaction.
pregnancy only if we're
saving the person's life
active peptic ulcer they
have a tendency to bleed
and current use of warfarin
with an INR greater than 1
.7 so we're we're in the
therapeutic range with warfarin
moving now to antiplatelet
agents aspirin the ADP
receptor antagonist and
glycoprotein 2b3a inhibitors this
scheme shows the points
the targets the points of
where the act the mechanisms
of action points so here's
our aspirin cycle oxygenase
one inhibits synthesis of
serboxane adenosine diphosphate
here which is going to
inhibit bit that platelet
recruitment and activation.
Remember thromboxane and
ADP are both molecules
within platelet granules
that are released when
platelets are activated
and degranulation occurs.
This one we're not
going to be talking
about, but it could
appear on a board exam.
and here we have our
GP2B3A inhibitors.
Beginning with aspirin, very
important antiplatelet drug.
Aspirin is
acetylsalicylic acid.
aspirin covalently acetylates
an allosteric site on
cyclooxygenases cox-1 is
the only one present within
platelets platelets are
a nucleate they once that
cyclooxygenase is inactivated
by the aspirin the
effect lasts the life of the
plate that platelet because
it can't make any new
proteins thromboxane a2 has
paracrine and autocrine
action which means it acts
locally it acts on itself
and acts on its neighbors
and it's a potent inducer of
local platelet aggregation
so here we are whoops it
it moved sorry here we
are thromboxane a2 right
here it is released along
with adenosine diphosphate
and serotonin and it goes
on to activate more
platelet and we get more
degranulation we get more
release of the factors of these
i should say molecules and
the the action increases
and now it came out
aspirin is taken ****** for
cardiovascular protection
which is what we're
using it for it's a low
dose the kind that can be
purchased in the pharmacy
or the supermarket is the
81 milligram even lower
doses are effective given
****** it's absorbed
into the portal circulation
which is which esterases
plasma esterases convert
it to salicylate in the
meanwhile it can get into
the platelets and and red
blood cells but we're
interested in platelets here
and it will bind to and
inactivate cox-1 it has a
very short half-life and
this is a low dose it goes
into the portal circulation
and it's rapidly metabolized
to salicylate salicylate
has its own activity
and it's inactivated in the
liver this is such a low
dose there's very little
systemic salicylate so
aspirin esterases into the
platelet very low salicylate
levels in the systemic
circulation salicylate
anyway does not have
antiplatelet effects and then the
salicylate metabolites
are excreted in the urine.
Very simple pharmacokinetics.
Mechanism of
action, irreversibly
acetylates an allosteric
site, inhibits
thromboxane synthesis.
Thromboxane A2
actions are prevented,
reduces platelet aggregation
and vasoconstriction. So
it reduces that whole
process from the thromboxane
side it doesn't reduce the
effect of the adenosine
diphosphate or the serotonin
so we get a reduction in
platelet aggregation but not
a com it's not completely
gone the effects last the
life of the platelet as
I mentioned so the patient
needs to be taking this 81
milligram or lower dose of
aspirin every single day
that the effect will accumulate
because the platelets
remain non-functional until
their life is over low
dose aspirin is used for
its antiplatelet effects for
cardiovascular protection
to reduce the risk of
thrombotic events. We're
reducing the potential for
platelet activation, and
therefore, in large clinical
trials, it demonstrated that
it reduced the risk of heart
attack and ischemic ******
in high-risk patients.
So it's used for
secondary prevention.
Secondary means after
cardiovascular Adverse
event occurred such as
myocardial infarction
to reduce the risk
of a subsequent event
And it can also be used
in patients who haven't
had the event But are
at high risk because
they have established
cardiovascular disease
Primary prevention
intermediate and high risk
Actually, I should have put
this under primary prevention
Because they haven't
had the event yet
And this needs
to be done really
in discussion with the patient.
There are risks
and benefits to be
thinking about in
low-risk patients.
The risks tend to be
higher than the benefits.
Some patients may want
to take the aspirin
prophylaxis. Some
patients may not want to.
So that's why it's
important to have
a conversation
with the patient.
And it also has other
uses, adjunctive uses.
Aspirin, even low-dose
aspirin, can cause
bleeding in the
gastrointestinal tract,
especially the upper
gastrointestinal tract.
Patients who are
scheduled for surgery,
aspirin should be
avoided for a couple
of weeks because of
this long effect,
antiplatelet effect.
Hypersensitivity,
aspirin is known to cause
hypersensitivity in
susceptible patients.
pregnancy well we usually
don't give NSAIDs to the
pregnant individual so the
question becomes well what
about this tiny dose of
aspirin is it okay and it
seems to be based on the
evidence that's accumulated
up to this point that low
doses for certain medical
conditions have not been
shown to cause fetal harm so
we're talking about the low
doses we're talking about
the benefit that of the
low doses of aspirin in
the pregnant individual
versus the risk to the fetus.
And of course,
it makes sense to
discontinue it prior to
delivery so that that
platelet function
can fully return.
The aspirin should not
be given to children
and adolescents
with a viral illness
because of the association
with Rye syndrome.
Now I mentioned adenosine
diphosphate comes
out of the granules
along with thromboxane.
So we have drugs that
block this effect of
adenosine diphosphate.
They block the receptor.
And they are called
P2Y12 receptor
inhibitors. P stands
for pureanergic.
2Y12 is the type of receptor.
This is an ADP receptor.
And we have the early
ones. Clopidogryl was the
first one, and prasagryl
came along afterwards.
These are called
cyanopyridines. They have
this structure, this
core in their structure.
I have one star on
clopidogryl. Prasagryl
is pretty much the same
except it can cause
some more there are a
couple of differences
Clopidogryl is what I
want you to remember
Then we have our reversible
inhibitors I put a star
in both of these because
they have some differences
So here I pointed out on
this figure the ADP receptor
antagonist at the P2Y12 So
what are these receptors?
They're ADP receptors. The
P2Y12 is the G-inhibitory
type of protein-coupled
receptor on the surface
of platelets. So it
inhibits adenylyl cyclase,
which decreases cyclic AMP
concentrations. But this
process actually leads
to other downstream
signaling events that result
in platelet aggregation.
So we're blocking this.
P2Y1 is a GQ type of
protein-coupled receptor
that activates a conformational
change in GP2B3A.
So the GP2B3A are present
on the plasma membrane,
but they're not active
until they're activated.
Once activated, they
will bind fibrinogen,
and that will cause
a cross-linking,
which attaches
platelets together.
Both of these receptor
types must be activated
by ADP in order to cause
platelet aggregation,
which is the clinical
rationale for drugs
that block P2Y12.
Just blocking the one
is going to reduce
platelet aggregation.
I've separated these
pharmacokinetic profiles by
irreversible and reversible
looking at well they're
all three of them are oral
kangrelor is an intravenous
bolus followed by an
infusion so I'm going to
start with kangrelor
actually because it's got a
different look kangrelor by
the way, is an ADP analog.
So it reaches its
maximal, its peak
concentration in less
than two minutes,
really quick, highly
protein bound.
ADP analog, so rapid
dephosphorylation in
plasma to an inactive
form. So it's going
to have to be given by
continuous infusion.
Basically, you can
see the excretion
is the same for all of them.
Three to six minutes after
the infusion is stopped,
very rapid return of the
platelet function. So now
that brings us back to
the orals these are the
ones that people take on a
routine basis clopidogrel
and prasagrel are oral
prodrugs now clopidogrel has
an onset in a couple of
days whereas prasagrel has
an onset in less than
half an hour so we ask
ourselves goodness sakes what's
the difference here Well,
the difference is the
conversion to the active.
Clopidogrel is
converted by CYP2C19,
yes, you need to remember this,
a small amount of the
dose. whereas prasagrel is
hydrolyzed which is a then
can by then it's converted
by cyp3a4 mainly to the
active thial metabolite
and that occurs much more
efficiently so that's the
basic reason for the
difference in the onset so if
a patient who's at thrombotic
risk is going to be
taking clopidogrel you need
to be remembering about
the onset in a couple of
days and clopidogrel is
nearly always
taken with aspirin
together with aspirin
prasagrel also
the clopidogrel has
a half-life of about
six hours but the
active metabolite thiol
is only about 30 minutes
but once it binds to the
platelet then because they're
irreversible inhibitors,
we see an effect of
about 11 days. It makes
sense because it's just
hanging out on the platelet.
Prasagrel,
active metabolite
around 7 hours. The
literature did not
indicate this platelet
-bound duration of
action. One would expect
anyway that it's
probably about the same.
but I didn't read
that anywhere.
Ticagrelor is reversible.
Onset in a couple of
hours is pretty quick.
It's active itself
and it's also got an
active metabolite and
about a 24-hour half-life
after it's discontinued
so those are the
pharmacokinetics cyp3a4
cyp3a4 and cyp2c19
you need to remember those
clopidogrel clopidogrel
and prasugrel are we now
of course it has a name
dual therapy with aspirin
secondary cardiovascular
product prevention
the ST elevation myocardial
infarction, acute
coronary syndrome, PCI,
and patients intolerant
to aspirin will be
getting this alone.
Ticagrelor, acute coronary
syndrome in patients with a
history of MI or unstable
angina, coronary artery
disease is primary prevention,
and minor ischemic ******.
all of them all antiplatelets
bleeding is a potential
adverse effect now CYP2C19
conversion to the active
metabolite you can just
imagine that we're going
to be talking about what
happens when 2C19 is not
working well if it's inhibited
or if the patient has an
allele such that they're
poor metabolizers that's
going to decrease the
conversion to the active style
and that could decrease the
therapeutic levels of it
bleeding higher rates than
with clopidogrel and is not
recommended in individuals
who are 75 years and older
please remember that particular
thing i know i didn't
put a star on prasugrel you
don't have to remember it
for the exam, but you should
be remembering it anyway.
Ticagrelor bleeding, of course.
Ticagrelor has been
associated with
thrombocytopenic
purpura. It's rare,
but some of the cases
have been fatal.
Radiarrhythmia and
shortness of breath
that tends to
resolve over time.
Ticagrelor bleeding.
Now the GP2B3A inhibitors,
receptor inhibitors. I put
A star on eptofibitide.
I want to draw your
attention to the bottom of
the slide. Epsiximab
was the first one in the
group, a monoclonal antibody
type of drug, obviously.
It's actually a fab fragment
of an immunoglobulin
that targets the
GP2B3A. It is no longer
available in the United
States. I'm not asking you
to memorize that one
because there's really no
reason other than it could
appear on a board exam.
Looking back at this
figure that we've seen
several times before,
here's our GP2B3A.
And these are the
receptors. and here's our
fibrinogen cross-linking
there are lots of these
gp2b 3as present on
the platelets and they
are inactive in resting
platelets so when the
platelet gets activated
they get activated the
fibotide is a cyclic peptide
torofaban is a synthetic
you can see they have
pretty short half lives but
not real short not like less
than five minutes so they
can be given as an IV
bolus and platelet function
is restored in about four
hours maybe a little longer
for tarofaman these are
intended these are not
intended for routine use
they're intended for as
adjuncts to PCI so and now
there are other drugs that
are also used with PCI their
use is really diminishing
compared to what it used
to be active abnormal
bleeding bleeding diastasis
****** hemorrhage and
elevated PT, INR. So
contraindication, severe hypertension,
major surgery. You can
predict these. Nobody
even has to tell you. These
are all related to potential
for terrible sequelae
as a result of bleeding.
This picture here is
just to help you see that
various factors will
activate the platelets, which
will cause the GP2B3A
receptors to be activated.
And you can see
the cross-linking.
Antidotes now.
We'll go through
these one by one.
Protamine completely reverses
unfractionated heparin,
partially reverses low
molecular weight heparin.
It acts quickly and
has a short half-life.
It should not be dosed,
overdosed, because
it needs to, because
it itself can cause
anticoagulation.
So there are dosing
recommendations on that.
You don't have to guess.
Vitamin K, it's also
called phytonodione, is the
reversal agent for warfarin
because it outcompetes
warfarin at the enzyme,
VKORC1. It can be given ******,
usually ******, IV in
case of severe bleeding.
And prothrombin
complex concentrate
for urgent reversal
of anticoagulants.
It contains the
coagulation factors,
vitamin K-dependent coagulation
factors and anticoagulation
factors. As you could
expect, by putting in these
factors, it can predispose
the patient to thrombi.
Idiracizumab is for the
direct thrombin inhibitor,
oral direct thrombin inhibitor,
oral dabigatran. It's
a MAB monoclonal
antibody fragment that
specifically binds
dabigatran and its active
glucuronide metabolites.
so it acts quickly it
has a fairly long
duration of about 24 hours
so that brings us to our
very brief summary this
is a little scheme
little concept map of the
drugs that we talked about
so you can see how all
their various classes
and how they're related
i put the summary of
the fibrinolytics here
urokinase is not
used anymore but it's
here it you may need
to know about it for
the boards alteplase
retiplase tenecteplase
and that concludes
this video on
fibrinolytics
antiplatelet drugs and the
reversal agents for
the anticoagulants